despite stricter rules and higher fines
passed this legislative session
catalytic converters continue to be
stolen we have brought you so many
stories about the rise of incidents here
in the valley but 8 news now reporter
Ryan Matthey found a fairly new way to
prevent it
do you have a name for them no just my
baby Sherry Wyman frequents California
beaches and Montana mountains in this RV
she got when she retired but when she
hit the road over the summer I started
driving it and the whole inside of the
car filled with exhaust gas her
catalytic converter was stolen from the
HOA storage unit where she lives she
says it took six months to get a new one
she's one victim of thousands by thieves
looking to sell the precious metals on
the inside Carfax reporting more than a
hundred and fifty three thousand thefts
nationally in 2022 in Las Vegas metro
police report more than 2600 in the same
year a replacement that could run
victims up to twenty five hundred
dollars according to AutoZone and as
thieves become smarter so are the
mechanics fixing it many vehicle owners
now turning to this to prevent theft
[Music]
we have those contact points that only
our shop knows catalytic converter
anti-theft protection better known as a
shield especially with rookie thieves
they don't really know what they're
looking for they'll just cut anything
Richard Castillo and Pete Pele of pele's
catalytic converters and more brought
the invention from the Bay Area last
year poly aluminum or stainless steel
Shields secured with heavy duty rivets
that make it harder to reach this and
even if you were to cut one of the
contact points you need to cut all four
to bring the whole thing down even if
you were to cut three off that four you
can't pull that shield down a feature
they say that does not interfere with
the vehicle functions or getting its
service but does interfere with the
thieves time or they're looking for a
window they're looking for about a
minute but if we can add on 5-10 minutes
they know there's another vehicle out
there without the protection leaving
fears of drivers like her in the rear
view mirror if anybody wants to take
this it's going to take them a while to
get to it